if a sub n is equal to N squared minus
10 over n plus 1 determine a sub 4 plus
a sub 9 well let's just think about each
of these independently a sub 4 a let me
write it this way a the fourth term so a
sub 4 so our n our lowercase n is going
to be 4 is going to be equal to where
everywhere we see an N in this explicit
definition for this sequence everywhere
we see an N we would replace it with a 4
so it's going to be equal to 4 squared
minus 10 over 4 over 4 plus 1 over 4
plus 1 which is equal to well let's see
that's 16 minus 10 over 5 which is equal
to 6 over 5 so that is a sub 4 that is
the fourth term now let's think about a
sub 9 so a sub 9 so once again
everywhere that we see an N we would
replace it with a 9 we're looking at
when lowercase n is equal to 9 or we're
looking at the 9th term so it's going to
be 9 squared let me do that blue color
just so we see what we're doing
9 squared in the green color minus 10
over 9 plus 1 over 9 plus 1 is equal to
well in the numerator we have 81 minus
10 81 minus 10 over 10 over 9 plus 1 and
so this is going to be equal to 70 1
over 10 now they want us to sum these
two things so that's going to be equal
to
it's going to be equal to 6/5 a sub 4 6
fifths plus a sub 9 which is 71 over
1070 1 over 10 but we can rewrite 6
fifths as being equal to 12 tenths 12
tenths and then 71 tenths so plus 71
over 10 which is equal to well if I have
12 10th and then I have another 70 110
so now I'm going to have 83 10
eighty-three tents and we're done